doesn't it blow your mind like a guy
like Tom Brady who I'm sure you get
asked about all the time how is this guy
place season after season with so few
injuries it's almost unbelievable isn't
it I mean you get pretty damn banged up
in a football game it's crazy
first of all Lady Luck plays a role
where anybody can get hurt
anybody can have an accident the joints
were designed by evolution or make or
whatever to be bending a certain way a
knee is supposed to bend this way back
and forth not sideways
no and when that happens you're tearing
ligaments tom is the best I've been
asked that question for many years and
Johnny you was my hero Otto Graham was
great sling and sammy baugh go back you
know these guys the guys you watched but
meantime tom has been challenged more in
recent history certainly with huge games
than anyone I could recollect and he
stepped up every time believable here's
a quarterback when I watch pro football
games college games you can literally
see and I actually lost games for our
team by throwing poorly throwing
interceptions I have not seen Tom Brady
lose a game for his team is she the
greatest that ever was I would have to
say he's the best at answering the
challenge there ever was yes I've not
seen anybody have that many big games
write and answer the challenge as well
as he has it's it's crazy to me I'm not
a super big knowledgeable guy about
football when I watched this guy play he
just pulls it out of somewhere and
that's the thing
how many guys did you play with in high
school who you would even consider who
were better than you but for some reason
they never make it to the pros like what
is that x-factor that makes a guy a pro
like you become one of the legends
desire to start with and again luck
injuries come into play in different
positions some guys physically they're
built to be a center a guard a tackle
and it's the team thing the quarterbacks
not going to go from here to there is do
anything without those cats blocking for
him up front right you know the best
quarterback that I know of that's not in
the Pro Football Hall of Fame
and he would be the first Manning into
the Pro Football Hall of Fame as their
daddy Archie right but he played for the
New Orleans ain't New Orleans ain't
right they used to wear bags over there
and Archie was running for his life all
the time